what is happening reject nation greg and
john here today we are going to watch
the trailer for the new guillermo del
toro movie nightmare alley yes there is
a 1946 movie this is not a remake of
that guillermo del toro said that he
actually read the book start working on
like perhaps developing the story i
think of ron pearlman before
he even saw the 1946 film so this is
more of an adaptation of that it's a
horror noir i'm excited to check it out
i thought it was coming out this morning
i was surprised it dropped when it did
let's do it
[Music]
step right up to my home one of the
unexplained mysteries of the universe
[Music]
is he willing to foe
[Music]
i am um
to offer you folks
one last chance
to witness the supreme oddity
where did it come
oh so excited
oh
[Music]
wow
can't wait for this man
can't wait
shape of water also a december release
as well
that looks great that looks great man
it's a de toro movie that is yes horror
noir but there's going to be no
supernatural elements in here i feel
like though that for those who i'm not
familiar with the book i haven't even
seen the original movie to be honest i
feel like that with the marketing of
this people will probably be inclined to
think that there are going to be
supernatural elements i keep saying man
or be scared of del toro with the kind
of visuals that they have the way the
framing is all done and the way the
colors are all lit it looks like classic
del toro so i feel like people might go
into this thinking that it is
supernatural but it is indeed not
supernatural but john what did you think
of the trailer while i pull up the
official plot synopsis to communicate to
the audience i was very dazzled by this
i mean i love any
del toro seems to really be at home in
the period piece
anything like any time he's going back
i'm really looking forward to
the vibes that he brings to it because i
feel like a lot of people associate him
with fairy tales and horror yes there's
certainly a lot of that but i feel like
he also does have a huge amount of love
and a huge amount of his creative dna
comes from classic cinema and so i'm
really excited to see him step into a
world like this that yeah won't be
heavily reliant on his classic creatures
giving him that you know sort of
restraint or that challenge for this
movie is really exciting to me because
now it can be all about the themes and
all about you know the beasts that lurk
within these characters so uh yeah as a
teaser i'm this got me really excited so
here's the plot description here from
searchlight pictures in nightmare alley
an ambitious kearny bradley cooper with
a talent for manipulating people with a
few well-chosen words hooks up with a
female psychiatrist cate blanchett who's
perfect for period piece movies she just
has that look who is even more dangerous
than he is and of course it's got this
fully fleshed out cast leonardo dicaprio
from my understanding was originally the
one who was cast of being here when he
couldn't do it bradley cooper had a
meeting with him i believe from the
discussion that they had it was mainly
about their shared perspectives on life
that formed this kinship between the two
of them i imagine that if this pans out
well for them and it looks like it will
because i love a good character descent
performance it's a noir piece so you
know that this is going to have so much
dissent happening i imagine this will
not be the last time him and bradley
cooper work together especially based
off of the way they said their chemistry
off-camera was and their creative
process together ultimately ended up
being but it's funny how like ron
perlman was the one who's like worked
with him of course on hellboy pacific
rim they have a reoccurring
collaboration process he's in the
trailer he's one of the bottom of the
list main cast members but uh he is a
big inspiration for why this movie
actually ended and ended up being made
to begin with all the way i think back
in the 90s is when he first read this
book i think this is a good transitional
piece for del toro who is coming off of
an oscar win for uh director and best
pitcher because it is a period piece but
i also think though that for fans of his
work who are so used to like
supernatural work that he often gets
involved with supernatural or sci-fi
like pacific rim they'll still have that
element of mysticism here brought to you
as you can they're dealing with like
carnies and i imagine that you'll still
get some awesome practical effects of
the people we're surrounded by like
already the locations and the production
design do look so grand and beautiful to
behold i love kind of like this isolated
nightmarish tone that it's striking just
from like the very first shot you got
this like loner here who is you know
traveling by bus and then when he sees
like the carnival taking place it's like
out of the middle of nowhere and the
only light coming from this darkness is
the carnival so there seems to be like a
lot of themes and mood being omitted
just alone from this trailer and you
know like one thing that he's really
good at doing is casting to obviously
bringing richard jenkins back from shape
of water rudy mara who i think is a
wonderful actress is getting a day to
shine here and also you know like
welcome to foe who's freaking fantastic
and perfectly cast for roles like this
too absolutely and tony collette one of
the most underrated actresses working
today glad she's getting the recognition
she absolutely deserves too yeah well it
seems like for bradley cooper like i was
just wondering like what's going to be
his next big thing because it seems like
he's in a position now where he's kind
of going to be cresting into the next
phase of his career and so to hear like
that partly his leading in this movie
came from you know having this
conversation with leonardo dicaprio who
is kind of up on that next or a couple
rungs you know up from him you know like
it seems like this is the perfect next
step in his career to you know really
being it's it's funny it's like the
ensemble around this is like oh yeah all
the character actors you would see in
like a top director's movie and bradley
cooper is definitely a-list but i feel
like you know this could make him one of
those guys who then you're going to see
in a bunch more movies like this just
being a veteran filling out the game
and i love like of course it's del toro
so you got like the romanticism elements
here that are like fully on display as
well it feels like pure del toro but
also something refreshingly different
from what he's offered before so guys
what do you think about the trailer are
you excited for this movie please leave
your thoughts down below subscribe click
that bell hit that like button uh keep a
lookout for a malignant movie reaction
haven't been promoting that at all but
anyway
anissa oliva anisa yesterday was having
an incredibly stressful
fourth of in 9 a.m and uh yesterday you
hit me up and you were asking me like
how are you doing i think you could tell
that i was pretty stressed out about
some stuff and i just want to say thank
you for uh being there for me during a
time that was uh really challenging so
you you rock you're just an amazing
friend i'm really happy to have you in
our lives and i mean that sincerely and
if you were a circus or a carnival
performer i would totally buy admission
tickets to go watch you perform even if
i didn't like what you were doing i
would still show my support because you
mean that much to me
you circus freak you
[Music]